yeah
[Music]
good afternoon and welcome everybody to
today's press conference where we will
unveil the results achieved by the
global scientific consortium event
horizon telescope which aims to capture
the first image of a black hole a very
warm welcome to all of you especially
those who have travelled from across
Europe to be here today we have very
little time before the actual
announcement goes live across the globe
in six simultaneous press conferences so
I will break with protocol a little and
hand the floor directly to European
Research Commissioner Carlos with us and
then we will turn to the five leading
scientists here on stage with us
involved in the discovery commissioner
thank you very much let me put the timer
thank you so much and it's a great honor
to be here today we really about to
announce a huge breakthrough for
Humanity we are about to take a picture
a picture of something that one man one
man alone dreamt imagine 100 years ago
in 1915 Albert Einstein imagined that
this idea that a very big weight
transforms geometry but when the mass is
too heavy you make a hole a mysterious
hole where nothing can get out of it
where all it's absorbed Michael Kramer
here from the ERC said the history of
science will be divided into the time
before the image and the time after the
image and you know for my generation
it's all about the imagination of
something that was in between science
and fiction at the age of 9 I went with
my father to watch the movie black hole
and I remember coming home and for the
first
time in my life nine years old thinking
about what's the meaning of life what am
I doing here
is there any parallel universe that's
what's really got me excited and
probably the question that we have to
ask to us to every down here that we
love science is to think about what
about in 100 years
Einstein was there 100 years ago but in
100 years what have we and what will be
the discovers the things that we'll
discover from these knowledge you know I
see Robert de Graaff there that wrote a
great book about the usefulness of
useless knowledge and Einstein could not
imagine it could not imagine what he
discovered he cannot imagine that one
day because he created and discovered
the antimatter that that would create
the PET scan that will save lives all
over the world so I'm really proud I'm
proud of science I'm proud of science
because science today is giving a lesson
to politicians he's showing that today
to take a picture of something that one
man grant 100 years ago you need people
from 40 different countries you need
people from all over the world but at
the same time that you're sitting here
there's six press conferences in
Washington in Tokyo in Taipei in
Shanghai and in Santiago de Chile and
I'm proud of Europe I'm proud of Europe
because we have invested so much in this
project we have put all together more
than 44 million euros because we can be
proud that Europe has a winning formula
and that winning formula is simple we
believe deeply in the freedom of science
we believe that scientists are the ones
to make the choices that the choices of
science are not done by politicians we
believe somehow in the intuition of
science Stephen Hawking once said
something that I would like to finish
these words today we do with this
excitement of us he said it is said that
facts are
sometimes stranger than fiction and know
where these more true than in the case
of black holes
black holes are stranger than anything
dreamed up by science fiction writers
but they are firmly matters of science
fact so ladies and gentlemen I think
that I've not been these excited since
when I came in 2014 if there's a big
moment for all of us is today and so
this big moment is shared with so many
in the public so many today here and I
want to invite all the team and for that
professor Hina Falcon is here so he will
come immediately to my place and tell
you and we will join all of us here in
the room will join him unveiling the
image so professor please come and I'll
go I still have to
[Applause]
now I have to fill the time actually
until we allowed to actually you know
start the unveiling sequence I thought I
used the time to introduce our team here
that's here today on stage with Monika
Moshe Brad suka from the Radford
University working on theory and imaging
of black holes
leshawna with solo from the great
University in Frankfurt we have Eduardo
of course from the Max Planck Institute
for radio astronomy and we have Antoine
Sene's was the director of the Max
Planck Institute for radio astronomy in
Bonn and also chair of the board of the
event horizon telescope and we have you
know a lot of team members here in the
front row
Michele camos already mentioned our co
PI you have a remote Elin was the
project manager of the event horizon
telescope glad you here with us today
Colin Lonsdale who is a co-chair of the
event horizon telescope project now we
have to start with the session we are
looking into space into towards the
galaxies a giant galaxy 500 billion
billion light years away from us sorry
five hundred billion billion kilometres
away from us very big galaxy was which
was suspected to host a supermassive
black hole in the very center hundred
and one years ago someone discovered a
streak of light which is plasma shooting
out of the centre of the Milky Way
marking the supermassive black hole I
never believed that this black hole was
as big as people said until we saw that
this is the nucleus of the galaxy m87
and this is the first ever image of a
black hole
that's das ist beard - Watson this is
the first image of a black hole
cut cela premia emerged in genoa what
you're seeing here is the result of many
many people working together you have
many probably seen many many images of
black holes before but they were all
simulations or animations and this is
suppression pressures to all of us
because this one is finally real what
you're looking at actually looks like a
ring of fire and it's actually created
by the 4th of gravity but the
deformation of space-time where light
actually goes around a black hole
almost in a circle and that creates that
circle that we see here it has a
diameter of I forgot the number actually
109 actually it's a hundred hundred
billion kilometers now now I got it
right it has hundred billion kilometers
but actually at the at the distance as a
huge distance of m87 it actually appear
as a mustard seed in Washington DC as
seen here from Brussels the size of the
ring is actually determined by the mass
of the black hole and very independent
of all the parameters of the black hole
all the modeling and so we can derive
from that size directly what the mass is
and it's six and a half billion times
the mass of the Sun that is an enormous
black hole that we see there we see also
more in there we see this dark region in
the middle I've always been asked by my
colleagues or told by my colleagues you
cannot see a black hole can you I think
they're right you cannot see a black
hole but you can actually see its shadow
and that's when the light actually
disappears behind the event horizon
creating that dark region that dark
shadow we see there and this is amazing
if you think about it where if you know
the story behind that image we're
looking at
reaching that we've never looked at
before reach we cannot really imagine
being there it feels like really looking
at the gates of Hell at the end of space
and time the event horizon the point of
no return
that is awe-inspiring to me at least but
it's also important for physics I think
my colleague would channel at solar will
now continue and explain to us why this
is so important cuesta la prima imagine
you MOOC on error so black holes are
part of our daily knowledge in fact even
a child knows what a black hole is and
the best definition I've received
actually comes from a child who simply
said well it's just a hole you cannot
fill so they're very simple but actually
extremely problematic in physics and
because of the properties they have the
first property is that a dev center in a
single point we think the laws of
physics break down we call this point a
singularity another property is that
this singularity is covered by a surface
a mathematical surface which is called
the event horizon gravity is so strong
on this surface that nothing not even
light can leave it and this surface
separates the interior from the exterior
and nothing from the interior can leave
and be transmitted to the exterior and
for a scientist this is a drama because
scientists want to know everything about
every corner of the universe so having a
region where you say you cannot
experiment there oh you can experiment
there but you cannot tell the results of
the of the experiment is extremely
frustrating and puzzling and the same
positing thought was shared by by
Einstein so how do you get to terms you
come to terms with this idea well the
first thing you want to do is convince
yourself that
black holes exist and in particularly
event horizon exist and the image we
have produced does exactly that so you
may wonder how do you know it is a black
hole and it is because it matches
extremely well with the prediction that
we can do from theory and is if shown in
this picture over here so on the left
there is the observed image on the right
there is a theoretical prediction and as
you can see the analogy is remarkable as
a matter of fact we have carried out
over these last six months the most
extensive investigation of what happens
to plasma to matter as we falls onto a
black hole we have used supercomputers
and highly advanced numerical codes to
calculate what happens and what we've
learned is that as matter falls onto the
black hole it will start rotating at
speeds which are close to the speed of
light and will become hot and emit light
especially in the radio frequencies
which are the ones that our telescopes
can capture but these simulations are
not sufficient if you want to know what
a black hole looks like as an image you
need to take into account that light
doesn't move on straight line in near a
black hole just contrary to this room
light can come from all sorts of places
and so light can can be bent can be
lensed and so the image that you obtain
by looking at a black hole can be very
counterintuitive and we have carried out
a very extensive investigation we built
tens of thousands of synthetic images
which cover all the possibilities that
we think are realistic conditions under
which a black hole is formed and this is
how we have come to conclude that this
is a black hole as predicted by Einstein
now you may ask what is the meaning of
this discovery for many of us it has
different meanings but there is one
meaning that we all share and is very
precious to us we have transformed a
mathematical concept that of the event
horizon something that I normally write
on a blackboard when I lecture on this
into a physical object something that we
can test and we can measure and we can
observe repeatedly and you may think
this is a minor thing actually this is a
fundamental first step in any scientific
progress
it's a scientific method be able to make
an experiment and they'd use from this
what are you know how does nature work
and now I'll leave the word to my
colleague Eduardo Rose to explain how
this beautiful experiment was first
carried out so astronomy is not
something that you do just from your
desk in many cases you have to embark in
an expedition and two years ago a large
team of astronomers and marking in
expeditions to the most remote places on
earth in places where the atmosphere is
thin and dry because we need to observe
at a wavelength where the atmosphere is
important and the important thing of
that is in these locations are also
facilities as you see they're like in on
thirty meter telescope or Alma or up X
with European technology and in these
telescopes the team of astronomers when
they are prepared with one eye into the
weather forecast
checking up all the systems of the
telescopes checking that everything
works and waiting for the go command
when the weather was good in all these
sites around the earth one of the things
you need to make such an image of a
black hole is to get a telescope as big
as the earth and to get that the small
pieces of this telescope are parabolic
antennas which you can see the locations
in the picture there these teams were
observing that we had a fantastic good
luck because we get good weather all
across the globe at the locations of the
telescopes these data where stars in
starting disks because you cannot you
can you not have optical fibers there
you have to fill boxes of hard disks
pack them into an airplane in some cases
waiting for several months like in the
South Pole until the winter over is gone
because it was night in April 2000 2000
and 2017 you weigh them and these data
are sent to processing centers where
they are played back as they were
recorded and synchronized with atomic
clocks these places are like in the
haystack Observatory in Massachusetts in
the US or in Bourne Mustang Institute
they are the so called correlators data
are playback they are evaluated and then
they are given to a further team who
checks this data every telescope is
different you need to correct for the
characteristics of each telescope put
all that together so that you get a
telescope as large as the earth and this
process needed also several months of
hard work assessment iterations until
people were sure ok this is the data
that now we can begin to image we can
extract the information from this
precious data which occupy 6 cubic
meters of of disk as I said to get
something like the image you have this
scene now and to know how you extract
this information and you get from that
my colleague Monica Marcia vodka
which was
you may wonder how this image was made
in the first place
event horizon telescope data is like in
complete puzzle set we actually only see
a pieces of the real true image and then
we have to fill in these gaps of these
missing pieces to construct the
physically possible image that is
actually matching our data this is
actually a very difficult process
therefore the imaging process has been
split into several phases at first at
the very beginning we were working on
this imaging completely alone each of us
this was remarkable
almost life-changing experience to see
an image of a black hole shadow popping
out on the screens of our ordinary
laptops next we form independent teams
that works completely independent and
from each other to repeat the imaging
process this was very necessary
important step because we wanted to get
rid of the human bias as much as
possible and Allah in the last phase we
took the longest time the imaging was
done very very carefully we are very
careful scientific analysis so what have
we learned from from the images and not
just from the images also from the data
there that are lying down lying
underneath this image so first of all we
have observed the source for four days
over the four days the ring is there the
the image looks almost exactly the same
we have also measured the size of this
ring over four days the size is always
the same it doesn't change we have also
measured the contrast between the ring
itself and the central darkness and the
contrast is as large as it is as it is
expected for the black hole shadow but
there is one more very peculiar thing
about this ring it's not really a full
ring it actually is much brighter bright
at the bottom side why is that our
mothers told us immediately that this
kind of structure can be only formed if
the source if something in the source is
rotating
what is rotating it could be the black
hole but also the matter around it
our boss can be rotating at the moment
the images are not yet sharp enough to
actually estimate or calculate the exact
speed of this rotation but these images
give us a sense of the direction of the
rotation which is a clockwise in the sky
so to summarise our images our data tell
us that we are looking at the shadow of
the black hole which has been predicted
by the other models of the black holes
that we have developed over the last few
decades and now Anton's answers will
give you will share some final remarks
on a current state and the future of the
event horizon telescope thank you so my
job now is to put it all together for
you the event horizon telescope is a
very ambitious project but one with a
very clear goal we want to image for the
first time the central black holes in
the galaxy m87 and in the Milky Way
today now six papers are appearing in
the Astrophysical Journal Letters
especially edition that show the image
and all the discussion that is needed to
convince our scientific colleagues and
in a few days the data from our
observations will be made public so that
scientists anywhere in the world can
verify our results so how have you made
this happen
we had to assemble a fleet a capable
fleet of the best and most sensitive
millimeter wave radio telescopes in the
world combined the supercomputers to
form one large radio telescope we had to
organize a team that now numbers to more
than 200 scientists from many
institutions around the world this is a
truly global collaboration we cannot
name all the
people that are participating in this
but representative for all of them I
want to recognize Colleen Lonsdale
director of haystack observatory and
together with my co-chair of the EHD
collaboration board he represents
together with our other friends here the
global partnership that we have all the
people that now are listening elsewhere
that worked together on this project the
preparation for these observations took
a long time I spoken this morning to
somebody who started 40 years ago
building millimeter telescopes and so
you can say several decades of
preparation went into what in 2017 was
for the team a very very difficult a
complicated experiment to perform this
experiment was successful this story is
not a story of one hero instead there
are many heroes to this story I'm proud
to work with these people and we salute
their achievement a number of them are
here in the room today ready to meet you
later so in Europe how were we able to
play a leading role in this endeavor for
most it is to combining forces we have
brought together astronomers observers
theoreticians and facilities together we
in fact were able to make a much better
result than we would have been able to
do individually of course in Europe we
have direct access to some of the most
powerful millimeter wave radio
telescopes the Anstey to varias tsunami
millimetric Iran's 30 meter telescope
was a crucial element in the north Alma
the Atacama Large millimeter are a where
the European Southern Observatory is a
key partner Mei was absolutely a
game-changer it enabled us to get the
sensitivity and the resolving power to
make these images happen
scientists in Europe for decades have
collected the capabilities have have
developed methods have acquired the
excellent skills that were needed to
participate in the scientific process in
this project in all places and last the
Scientific developed the technical
development capability that we have to
build instrumentation state-of-the-art
instrumentation that we need is second
to none here in Europe lastly lastly the
public funds the taxpayer money that was
spent on our basic research here both
from national resources but also from
the European Union from European
Research Council and from raiding it was
crucial and making this excellence
happen we appreciate that very much
and we hope we can come back
so where we where we going from here m87
in the bag
we are confident that very soon we'll
complete the analysis of Sagittarius a
star we will go back to observe and so
please stay tuned we'll come back we
already underway improving the array
foremost Iran's expanded noemi array
that they will soon finish will again be
a game-changer for our trade Alma will
offer us improved capabilities and the
Greenland telescope and perhaps the
African millimetre telescope project
will make critical contributions to
improving the quality of the EHT with
all of this we are well placed to go
into the next step of this journey I
think that we will be able to confirm a
lot of the signs that we expecting but
much more important we will be able with
this machine to make discoveries of the
unexpected and that's the most
fascinating in science I personally like
to say that I will think of a time
before and after I saw for the first
time this image you mentioned this also
today I believe for all of us marks the
beginning of the day after for all of us
thank you very much for your support and
thank you for your interest in our
science now we will be ready to take
your questions thank you
[Applause]
thank you much for these presentations
and I dare say our press room will
always be open for such extraordinary
announcements now we can turn to your
media questions let me point out that
we've published abandoned not only press
material and words but more importantly
audio-visual material on the Commission
website may I please ask you to
introduce yourselves by name and media
starting in the middle thank you very
much
my name is Nicholas Wallace I'm policy
editor science business my question is
for commissioner what US you said that
this is the most excited you've been
since you took office in 2014 my
question is do you expect any more
excitement before your term ends and if
not given that this was an international
project that the Commission contributed
to what should be next for the EU and
international collaboration in science
what do you think the next big thing
should be for the next commissioner
Thanks thank you very much for the the
question and yes I mean I think that
this is really the pinnacle I mean I I
had exciting moments exciting political
moments exciting when I was able to put
forward to the College of Commissioners
a proposal for 100 billion euros for the
next science program that really made my
heart beat very much and made me more
nervous about it at the time in a
positive way when then we went to the
Parliament and the council and we
discussed and a couple of weeks ago we
achieved really something unique is that
we had that agreement we the countries
and the Parliament for the content of
that problem of the future and so one of
the things that is in that program
answers your question which is that is
link had between the citizens and
science and how important is that and so
we want to define this idea of the
missions the
and driven science because we want
European citizens to feel connected and
that connection that happened here today
it's a proof of that you know I've never
seen these rooms so full or if I've seen
it was not for positive reasons were for
reasons of crisis and not for positive
things and it's so refreshing to come
here to see so many people to see people
clap I mean it's very rare in a press
room to have people clapping and and so
I think that is a sign for politicians
that you should look at science in
Europe as really the engine of growth
and the only way forward to be the
center and so in terms of international
collaboration and I've said it so many
times I really believe that this is all
about the European program to be open to
the world I mean we are discussing with
countries like Canada New Zealand we're
discussing around the world to have
people that want to be part of the
European program because the European
program has the history of Europe is not
about Europe is about getting people
together is more than Europe we are
bigger than that and that what makes
European a center stage and so I think
there's a really for the next couple of
years that will be the mission the
mission is to get everybody on board in
a place that is quite unique you know I
mean there's not a lot of places in the
world where you have the funding that we
have for fundamental science we have
jean-pierre bourguignon sitting there
with the European Research Council I
mean that's quite unique and so I'm
proud of that and yes today is a really
a proud moment it's for for the question
my name is Natalia Jack I'm with
Bloomberg I was hoping that you could
help us understand a bit what what
impact this discovery has on our
understanding of conventional physics
laws and how that's going to change now
especially with Albert Einstein's theory
of relativity thank you
so you know the theory is eagerly
waiting for confirmations an ice and
theory of relativity is the one that we
know best and the one that has so far
passed all the tests and this is not a
very important test this is the first
ever image and this gives us great
confidence that relativity is the one we
understand in the strong field regime
what curvature is very very strong
actually follows exactly what I son
predicted it's literature there are a
lot of ideas for alternatives of black
holes and there's something you finally
can actually test we only start just
starting to do this we can now say it's
not a wormhole for example but many
other things we will test in the future
but it can be done now now it becomes
experimental science and we have
Croatian ways and we have you know
pulsars all testing gravity in an area
in a regime which has been unaccessible
before so I think this really transforms
a study of gravity in a fundamental way
you will need different methods
different scales gentleman here in the
front you can take a mic on your side
and in the seat
now I'm Davide castle Vicky from nature
magazine how many questions do I get
start with one and then we'll okay can
you tell us if you found any information
about Sagittarius a star I was to say
was supposed to say that we actually
focused all our attention on m87
when we saw the very first results
because we knew this one's going to be
awesome
the the issue with Sagittarius a star is
is thousand times smaller it's thousand
times closer so it has the same shadow
size but also times faster so if you
want to take an image of that source
it's like take an image of a toddler
which moves around for eight hours and
you try to get a still image while m87
is a big bear thousand times slower
you know hibernating they're not moving
much within this eight hours so that
makes it much easier we were just lucky
that m87 was so large it could have been
much smaller we didn't know that before
and so once we saw that we focus
everything on that one so you know we'll
still take a little more time to work on
such a star we may come back to you
later time permitting I think I saw some
other show of hands yes back there
Marco's first I leave Marcos Becker with
their Spiegel
I see that the black hole seem to behave
nicely and follow the predictions but
maybe you can explain to us what kinds
of new insights you have gained and how
they for the bases for possible new
research and new insights in the future
thank you
so so far our observation is actually
exactly what we have expected but I
think there will be more possibilities
in the future to investigate the
behavior of this black hole
we probably basically would have to make
it take movies not just static images
yeah we also can learn something about
the jet formation this the supermassive
black hole is very famous for is is huge
kiloparsecs scale jet so now we know how
this jet is actually coming out from the
black hole so this is a huge new insight
of how relativistic Jets are produced
thank you then we had a question right
in front of Marcus there yeah okay well
maybe while you continue thinking about
questions or we come back to the nature
we also have a number of people
following us on social media and online
and they also had the opportunity to ask
us questions so I'll take a couple of
those firstly how can you take photos
without light well radio is also light
the radio waves as light as the eye that
enters into these detectors we have here
which are called eyes we use the light
the waves that come from the remote
black hole region in such a quite tricky
way because the same light that arrives
to the earth the same wave comes to all
the different telescope and we drop this
front of light in our computers we can
then reproduce and play back that but
this is also the radio light which is
also the same light that comes into the
mobile phones that we are working in the
alum in the electromagnetic spectrum
then we can use this light to see the
black Hostin scene image is actually
light that is produced by plasma around
the black hole it's true that we cannot
see the black how it's it's black so you
cannot see it but we we see its shadow
that is being cast on this glowing
plasma so we are actually taking a
picture
of light one little detail we think that
the black hole is actually really
engulfed in an optically thin
transparent glowing fog of radio
emitting material and so the fact that
you see nothing in the center is
actually quite significant we'll take
another question which i think is rather
directed that the Commissioner Moyes
which is how will the you support
astronomy that we're now all very
fascinated about in the next year
research funding program I think first
we support it in the name of our new
program
you see event horizon horizon Europe I
never thought about that before but I
think he's a good one I think that the
way it's very important that Europe
keeps on being the leader of fundamental
science in the world I mean this where
we are at our best and so when we
approached on this proposal for the the
countries and for the Parliament to go
from 13 billion years for the European
Research Council to 17 billion years of
the European Research Council
that's exactly about fundamental science
and that's exactly to put these priority
as European priority because if we can
differentiate there I think that we can
differentiate for the future of our
children because what I love about
fundamental science and I think that's
where the question from the journalist
over there which was but what do you
take from here what are the impact in
the things that we don't know the so
many impacts that these will have in the
future I think that it's same thing to
look at the people that are young now
the very young ones and think the impact
that they will see from these in 50
years and the fact that we don't know
and that's something that is for the
good of Europe and for the good of the
world so I think that we if there's a
place in the world that invests in
fundamental science it's us and we
should keep doing that for the future so
on the program horizon Europe
we will keep investing very heavily on
fundamental science
of course my perspective and that is
that it is very important to see that
Europe is investing in the great brains
and at the same time it's also very
important to see that we have in Europe
this technological and this edge with
our facilities and I will say that the
support that we've had from the Union in
actually making these facilities
accessible 10 European to pan-european
scientists has been very important and
even more important has been the seed
funding that we have received so that
the technology development can be done
together at various institutions and so
it's the the balance of investing in the
individual talent the brains and
investing into state-of-the-art
infrastructures that really sets us
apart thank you let's come back to
questions in the room yes hello from
Netherlands I question about the
accretion disk of black holes they all
black holes seems to have an accretion
disk did you try to have an image of
that accretion yes - and how do I see
the accretion disk
compared to this image is it outside of
this horizon or I don't know you
correctly said these black holes are not
in vacuum they are surrounded by matter
and mutton naturally folds and circles
around it now in this very image thus
the the accretion disk is essentially as
my end we're seeing it almost face on
and it so it happens that matter that
rotates in this in particular in
clockwise direction will be pushing
towards us it's all of this emission and
this is why the bottom line is more
bright than the top part because is what
is called Doppler beamed it's more
intense because of a relativistic effect
so you can imagine other ways matter
going around in a clockwise in a in a
kind of accretion disk the disk is not
thin as we normally see in science
fiction it's a very thick accretion disk
and the simulation that you will find
online will get clarified is a bit
better
would like to add here that it is okay
you know this image can have different
interpretation and it is possible that
we are actually that this ring is
actually the inner edge of the accretion
disk or the inner edge of the jet that's
where it starts the problem that we have
is that the light bending actually
blends everything together so when you
look at low radio frequencies you see
the jet as you go to high frequency you
get closer and closer to the event
horizon that's what we see that's why I
went to this high frequency because
that's where we actually start engulfing
the entire black hole that we where we
can resolve the black hole but that's
where the innermost region is and then
everything gets blend together by light
bending so if you look again at the
simulations then you get a much better
idea of what we think there is the black
sea it didn't have a name and in analogy
to the other source that we studies
Sagittarius a star we just use this
short version called m87 star which does
mean it's a star but just now the star
actually means it's a very exciting
source it's a one of the most exciting
sources in in m87 so you know an amusing
note the the reason why a name which has
been associated and proposed for this
black hole so will actually have a
proper name besides just a number thank
you it's a good idea for a contest
though yes back here down here
push the button and wait until it turns
red yeah cool mutters VOD built-in
television have you found something
which was unexpected or contradicted
Einstein's relativity theory
unfortunately not you know you know I
think it was less you know mind-blowing
to see that in the first place
had it been completely different from
our expectations we would have had to
puzzle for like two more years to really
you know see it had we done something
wrong of course at some point you hope
to find something that you did not
expect in your simulations but now
everything seems to fit perfectly
actually amazingly perfect and I should
say actually Monica published a short
English publish a paper 2016 if you just
convolve it to what we observe today
it's almost what we see now thank you
any further questions in the room yes
can you really exclude any possible may
be remotely possible alternative
explanation so or could it be for
instance connected to the area that the
weather jet is launched actually no we
cannot exclude there are many
alternatives to black holes and there
are many black holes in other
alternative theories of gravity what we
are doing right now is excluding some of
them for instance wormholes as I know as
mentioned we can exclude boson stars
which is also a very popular alternative
there are alternatives which are more
subtle and will require future
observations but what we see is
consistent with Einsteins and that's the
simplest explanation all of other
explanation requires some more exotic
explanation that would be difficult to
explain with astrophysics for instance
but are still allowed by the theory one
little edition we ran our simulations
actually all kinds of physical scenario
so we had actually dis dominated Jet
dominators emission would come from all
over the place and turned out it almost
always looked the same because of the
light bending that is a dominating
effect so you know we simulated all of
that and you know you know whatever
wherever it comes from the gr winds and
sort of makes that shadow that was
actually the predictions and seemed to
work out very nicely
you will take another question from
social media are there any other
galaxies that we know of where we might
be able to observe black holes yes they
are and they are in our list I mean
these galaxies and say terraces that are
very strong as long as we develop our
telescopes to go to bigger collecting
surfaces which make us more sensitive to
the photons coming from the universe we
will tick our list and check for the
next ones if you want to resolve the
black hole you have to go to a higher
resolution and you need telescope larger
than the earth and that you can only do
from space and so watch for some papers
in the next couple of weeks or so which
will describe how you could do this do
we have any final questions yes the
gentleman back there you have a
microphone and Julian or just a European
citizen astonished by what you have
achieved my congratulations I simply
wanted to ask you did some simulations
to give you some expectation of what you
would be looking for in your results
according to the parameters of your
modeling did he give you any insight
into the other parameters of the black
hole such as its magnetic field or its
angular momentum did it shed any light
on the generation of the Jets yes
thank you for your question citizen
[Laughter]
that's very very important rotation of
the black hole is very difficult
quantity to measure and because of this
blending of the light coming out of from
the jet or the accretion disk it's very
difficult for us and and this is
something we discussed in the papers to
measure exactly how rapidly the black
hole is spinning but we think it is
spinning because otherwise it will not
make sense in terms of the energetics of
the jet and so we think it's spinning
and actually if you want to ask well
what is the spinning direction we think
it's pointing away from us that's our
best guess at the moment and learning
about magnetic fields that's something
that we are working on but right now we
don't have a conclusive answer yet again
these are much higher much more
difficult quantities to measure and we
hope with with the future observation to
nail down also this information I would
like to add here that at the moment we
have a sense of rotation so this is
something that I mentioned that it is
clockwise on the sky so this is
something that we are we are certain
about I may add on the magnetic fields
that these data have still treasures
waiting for us we have obtained the
total intensity images but we are
working also in the polarized light
which is also in the data and when we
learn about the polarized light we also
learn about the magnetic fields this is
one of the next things in our to-do list
thank you we will be closing this press
conference shortly before I invite
Commission and with us to formally and
officially close the press conference
let me of course thank our speakers here
and all of you for being here today I
would also like to thank our
interpreters and technicians because
it's not every day that they have to in
translate such a scientific language and
also put up all this show our scientists
will actually be with us till afterwards
so if journalists belatedly think of any
questions they're welcome to approach
them and with that Commissioner the
floor is yours for the closing remarks
just a word of thanks a word of thanks
to everyone for this amazing moment but
the word of thanks for the courage
because you know is not easy for the
scientists to take the risk I mean we
were taking a risk of being here today
and that is something that is important
for Europe that you take the risk to be
here you take the risk to be in this
moment and to show to people the
importance of science and more important
to that is that you made us dream today
and an important moment you know he goes
through difficult times a lot of crises
a lot of problems and sometimes we need
these moments and this morning when I
was reading a speech from Stephen
Hawking that he delivered in Chile quite
a long ago I thought that I would finish
with a quote from him that would inspire
us to be hopeful about the future
and will inspire the leaders and the
prime ministers and the presidents that
are here today in Brussels he said the
following black holes and has black as
they are painted they are not eternal
prisons as we thought things can get out
of a black hole both to the outside and
possibly to another universe so if you
feel you are in a black hole don't give
up there is always a way out
thank you all let me also invite you to
join us outside for those who are
physically present here today for the
exhibition that we have on the project
and with this we conclude the press
conference thank you